ja selten waren kinder so unglücklich
wie aktuell laut einer studie der tu
dortmund wächst eine generation von
unglücklichen kindern heran das
interessante an der studie ist dass bei
kindern das psychische wohlbefinden vor
allem seit dem frühjahr 2020 stark
bergab gegangen ist ich muss ganz klar
sagen schuld daran sind zum einen
natürlich die digitalisierung aber eben
auch die pandemie die studie hat mich
wirklich schockiert und ich finde man
muss maßnahmen ergreifen um dagegen
vorzugehen
herr kraus natürlich eine steilvorlage
an sie waren die kinder früher
glücklicher wenn sie sich ja gut da gibt
es keine absoluten maßstäbe ja das sind
immer befragungen und da gibt es kein
meeting ist
natürlich hat ist eigentlich in den voll
da ganz kurz rein zu gehen die studie
hat 2018 schon angefangen also die haben
nicht erst angefangen zu messen ab 2020
also jaffa corona die ich gebe den in
den beiden punkten was die ursachen
regierung betrifft vollkommen recht es
fehlt
das soziale puls sein
die kinder waren zu hause eingesperrt
sie konnten sich in der schule im
sportunterricht der pausenhof im
schulbus nicht austoben zu hause haben
sie auch kaum gleichaltrige unsere
familien wenn sie überhaupt kinder haben
haben die kinder soll von 1,3 im schnitt
also das ist ja auch ein ergebnis der
demografischen entwicklung und natürlich
spielt die digitalisierung eine rolle
wir wissen schon seit jahren dass unsere
kinder im alter zwischen zehn und 16
guter letzt ein bisschen nach mehr zeit
beim datteln und vor dem bildschirm und
an welchen schulen lassen nach meiner
verschärfte natürlich sage ich ja beide
dinge spielen eine rolle allerdings und
jetzt kommt ein bisschen meinem eine
gegenthese ich glaube dass wir in der
erziehung der letzten 20 30 jahren der
30 jahre den kindern auch überzogene
erwartungen vermittelt haben was
lebensglück betrifft wir sie gepampert
haben ja du kannst immer alles gleich
haben und du kannst immer glücklich
werden gut das ist das ergebnis von
helikopter eltern das paper warum
schauen sie mich sah
das buch ihr daraus zu lesen sich ein
punkt ist wenn er darüber dass du jetzt
nicht alle eltern den hügel deutschland
popularisiert vor neun jahren nein das
ist schon auch das ergebnis dass unsere
jungen leute nicht mehr gelernt haben
und das ist ein produkt der erziehung
auch in der schule die von gewissene
bewohner einmal auch mit unglücklichen
lagen fertig zu werden dann hatte ich
aber ganz kurz zwischen gehen was
bedeutet denn junge leute also wenn sie
jetzt sagen 20 bis 30 ich bin jetzt 28
würde ich da auch noch dazu gehören nein
ich rede jetzt von denen im ersten
zweiten lebensjahrzehnt bis sie
volljährig sind also bis 20 ist 18 bis
sie flügge werden ja ich frage mich ob
man sich das so einfach machen kann hat
man sagen kann das ist alles so ein
produkt von helikopter eltern weil es
gibt auch ganz ganz viele kinder die
sind nicht das produkt von helikopter
eltern die sitzen zu hause haben auch
wenn der pandemie zu hause gesessen auch
nicht genau wie die er sicherlich naja
aber auch die lebenswirklichkeit will
wenn sie zu zuhört meinte dass dann ein
bisschen mehrere zu 1500 mann wegen 100
quadrat mit der wohnung leben oder 80
quadratmeter wohnung leben obwohl die
mutter vielleicht irgendwelche arbeiten
machen muss der vater auch zu hause weil
es ihm um auf wir sind da ist man froh
wenn das kind so ein bisschen er
vorsitzt und endlich mal ruhe ist auch
eine und das ist dann gewissen so gibt
da rein dass man endlich die welt
entdeckt und immer weiter führt das ist
ja nachvollziehbar nur die frage ist wie
kommt man da wieder raus also
wahrzunehmen dass die menschen in
solchen situationen auch nicht
willentlich sind sondern auch mal
reingeschmissen werden und durch die
pandemie sich das unglaublich verstärkt
hat ich glaube das gehört auch dazu
anzuerkennen dass menschen ist auch
nicht mehr einfach haben ja das ist
richtig es gibt zwei problembereiche es
gibt die kinder die
überbehütete und über betreut werden die
habe ich genannt und es gibt die
geschichte eltern nicht kümmern oder
nicht wie man können das ist jetzt aber
auch sehr schwarz weiß als würde es gab
also als würde es nur die helikopter und
nur die eltern geben die sich nicht
registrieren
irgendwo noch wenn die gerechnet
halbwegs vernünftig läuft
sie sprachen das thema noten an dass ich
oder die die frage ob man eigentlich
heutzutage noch lernt auch mit negativen
erfahrungen umzugehen und ich glaube der
punkt ist durchaus richtig und er ist
auch durchaus wichtig den sie machen
denn mein eindruck ist auch das wird
aber auch in schulen nicht mehr geleert
dieses umgehen mit einer negativen mit
einer negativen erfahrung dass wir beim
thema noten isolations schnelleren
stelle in der grundschule gehen als
eigene vier so gut wie gar nicht mehr 56
punkte heraus lassen und auch sie haben
das thema ja auch in schulnoten generell
angesprochen wenn man sieht wie viele
menschen heute ein 1,0 abitur machen das
war vor zehn noch vor 15 jahren eine
totale seltenheit sie bekommen in den
schulen eine 1 - mit zwei drei fehler in
einer arbeit wo man sagen muss das alles
aber es ist keine 1 mehr eine zwei mit
fehlern wo man sein wir das alles aber
keine zwei mehr also man versucht doch
extrem frustration bei schülerinnen und
schülern vorzubeugen über dieses
notensystem und es ist ja interessant
dass trotz der ganzen debatten die wir
seit über 20 jahren haben weder du weißt
du was damals auch teil der
bundesregierung thema pisa tests teams
tests dass wir eigentlich was das
leistungsniveau an g 20 jahre später
eigentlich nicht besser geworden sind
sondern immer noch sagen die deutschen
im mittelfeld mal geht es ein bisschen
rauf im internationalen vergleich mal
wieder ein bisschen runter und das ist
das was mich eigentlich umtreibt da
komme ich auf ein anderes thema von der
frustration hin aber zum thema bildung
und muss sagen wird eigentlich das
richtige gelehrt wird genug gelehrt und
haben wir angst jungen leuten auch
zuzumuten mal eine frustration zu
erleben weil wir sie nicht zu trauen und
wir müssten sie eigentlich zutrauen
damit sie daraus kraft schöpfen
motivation oder in denen dinge besser
hätten wir in weinheim story gemacht
ganz genau noch nicht so lange her oder
sozialamt ein herbie geschenkt worden
also wenn man das sehr kalte person
letzten jahren so entwickeln nein auf
gar keinen fall also ich musste richtig
ackern mich hinsetzen was dafür tun und
der installation slammer wurde auch
genug ausgeschöpft ja was ist denn deine
lösung durch die these mitgebracht was
würdest du dir wünschen für deutschland
ich glaube einfach dass es super wichtig
ist dass man mit programmen dagegen
vorgeht also man sieht es ja auch zum
beispiel ein fußballverein es gibt ein
wirkliches vereins sterben in
deutschland die leute oder die jungen
leute gehen nicht mehr raus die machen
keine vernünftigen hobbys mehr die
sitzen nur noch vortritt und diesen
ganzen neuen online geschichten ich
glaube es ist super wichtig dass man das
meer fördert in der schule auch mal
fördert natürlich ist digitalisierung
wahnsinnig wichtig und das dürfen wir
nicht außen vor lassen
und sollte auch da mehr gefördert werden
aber gleichzeitig eben auch wirklich
dieses geht wieder raus spielt räuber
und gendarm falls man das noch sagen
darf ich weiß es nicht